because it's sort of an ex that's what  the exchange is it's a man's time  attention and resources and a change for  exchange for sexual access so if you  keep accepting [ __ ] from dudes like I  think at some point you should probably  sleep with them or cut it off yeah yeah  like it's not like why are we playing  these games like we don't we don't know  we know what the exchange is like you  can't go blindly into a date yeah with a  guy like yeah whatever you spent like  two like let's say three four bills on  dinner and you expect him to not sleep  with you no I'm not saying it's right  but I'm saying have that impression that  you think that he wants to sleep with  you yeah because look at the exchange  it's a clear exchange